make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so after what seems like an
eternity of waiting the war of realms
has finally begun and it's just like oh
my god okay
I'm caught like I'm gonna say right now
I don't care what anybody says
Jason Aaron's run on Thor is the
greatest run on Thor there's ever been
and there's no arguing that point that's
just the way it is I be reading Thor
since Dan Jergens started writing it in
the 1990s like I've been reading Thor
for a long time and like the run of
Jason Aaron is the best run like it's
it's definitively the best run so
basically all the realms are in shambles
right now literally Midgard which is
basically earth it's like the only realm
that's not on the brink of total
destruction right like this is the whole
basis behind war round so for those
people who haven't really kept up with
anything the way this works is you
basically have Malekith the accursed
he's a dark elf and he's been around for
a long long time really the first big
campaign he went on was when he got his
hands on the casket of ancient winters
back in the day but the idea here is
that what Malekith had basically been
doing was launching this onslaught
unlike all of the realms that are out
there right like Jotunheim and and all
that stuff yon Niflheim and everything
and basically like essentially either
conquered them all or killed almost
everybody there but it's sort of like
they're all just like derelict spaces
now as really all they are everybody
who's worth anything has either been
killed or they fled as refugees not only
that for Asgard itself oh it's it's it's
been torn asunder and we know that
because all that happened as a result of
of man GOG right like that was the whole
basis behind the man gods story that man
GOG was unleashed and when that happened
like being one of the only beings that
like Odin fears that owns actually like
the only thing that owns actually afraid
of man GOG basically stormed Asgard and
just wrecked everything destroyed the
Bifrost bridge almost killed Odin like
all the the various as guardians who
normally reside here have left and gone
to earth because it's the only safe
haven and so it makes sense when Odin
being the only person residing on Asgard
now is basically met by the arrival of
the of like the Dark Elves who take him
out pretty easily now there's a reason
why this happens because at the outset
like for those who aren't really sure
who haven't really been keeping up at
the outset it would be like will Odin's
way too powerful to be killed by dark
elves and that's true under normal
circumstances but do not forget man God
took almost all the power of Odin to
basically hold at bay
let alone be like defeated by Jane
Foster like he was a last major story
out for her character so the OD force is
readily to
at the moment like it's almost
non-existent there's a little bit left
but not enough for Odin to really do
anything with otherwise he would have
fixed Asgard and so with him being in
such a weakened state he's taken out
pretty quickly and so what this does is
it switches over to Thor now the cool
thing about this with Thor being in New
York alongside a lot of the other guys
guardians kind of spread across the
world that what this does is it leads to
the arrival of Loki now Loki's been kind
of like a wild card throughout the whole
war of realms right like in the
beginning of the war of realms it seemed
like he was kind of an agent well he was
a double agent he was working on behalf
of of Malekith
but while Malekith wasn't really aware
of it was actually working for his mom
only for us to find out he was just kind
of pursuing his own goals and was
legitimately sided with Malekith and so
when that happened like he stabbed his
mom in the back and she was you know
basically unconscious for a while things
like that and it kind of allowed Jane
Foster to do her own thing what we end
up having to having to come to grips
with here and the same thing that Thor
has to deal with is the answer to the
question who's side is Loki really on
it's the one question nobody really
seems to be able to answer no one knows
whose side Loki's on because Loki could
be on anybody's side but with Loki
showing up here essentially like injured
in such an extreme degree almost on the
verge of death the response of Thor is
take me to where Malekith is because the
idea behind Odin's son here is like okay
so one he's wielding three hammers which
is pretty awesome but literally like
easy let's talk about that for second
Thor wielding three hammers that is
amazing I look that's one of things I
love about Jason Aaron's run right like
during god of thunder
he was he had like two hammers and like
the necros sword but nonetheless it's
it's pretty insane in this this little
bit of storytelling here but Thor's
whole stance is this war starts with
Malekith Thor has to be the one to
defeat him now the reality of the
situation is that Malekith is not
someone who can be easily defeated by
Thor because Malekith has all all manner
of like you know mystic mystic arts and
things like that at his disposal so it's
not like Thor can just run up on him hit
him with a hammer you know [ __ ] him over
the head one good time and that's the
end of that it doesn't really work that
way there's a better chance of defeating
Malekith with Thor then without fort and
that's literally what he says is like
take me to Malekith he's the one that
started all this I know that we lost the
Bifrost
but Malekith has the ability to
basically open his own portals to give
his people access to different locations
give like take me into Malekith and I
will wipe him out like I will I will
destroy him now
the funny thing about it is that the way
the Jason Aaron writes this it really
almost kind of hits on the head that
like Loki cannot teleport anywhere he
wants
which is actually not true over the
years and marwah comics it's kind of an
established that loki has access to
these different back doors to different
dimensions the way this works when it
comes to accessing dimensions as
technically there's the front door which
is like the direction most people take
right like the Bifrost is like the front
door to a different dimension look he
knows the back doors he can sneak in and
out to the of these different places
without aiming about anybody ever really
realizing he was there but in the way
it's written here it almost seems like
he can't now this could also be the fact
that like one of the things that
Malekith did it's cut off people's
access to that realm which is entirely
possible but it's not really stated here
it's just the Bifrost is gone we can't
access those realms and so again it
seems kind of it seems to limit the idea
that like even if Loki can teleport in
and out of those places that Thor cannot
go with him it's kind of a weird
situation because it seems to kind of
contradict a lot of the established
history when it comes to Loki and the
places he's able to access but at the
end of the day the same has made you
know how to get in and out of these
places by accessing the kind of backdoor
Briah Bifrost that Malekith uses take me
to where he's at and when that happens
Loki's basically whisked away to
Jotunheim which is where Malekith is not
an immediately Thor picks up on that
Malekith is not here and so with that
being the case the response of Thor is
there's no AI Malecha this here take me
to where he's at and the response of
Loki is I already have only for us to
find out that Malik youth is
masquerading as Loki now this is a very
important thing here and the reason why
is because it really hits the nail on
the head of just how capable Malekith is
and that's one of the reasons why the
war of realms is so cool is because in a
lot of ways Malekith is a pretty obscure
character to the non comic book reader
and even to some of the coming some of
the normal color book readers as well
right like if I walk up to somebody
who's been reading Marvel Comics or
reading DC Comics for five years and I
showed him a picture of Malekith they
probably won't know who he is but when
you go through and you look at like the
lengthy history of his character he's
very low-key esque in regard to how he
functions and that's what makes Malekith
so cool is because what better way to
lure Thor away than to basically portray
himself as Loki not because Thor would
ally himself with Loki but because again
Loki knows all the back door channels
Loki is the best way by which Thor can
immediately access Malekith and take him
out and that's the one thing Thor wants
the most is to eliminate Malekith and so
that's why this is so cool and that's
why it works so well because then what
happens is it's essentially just like
this giant battle between Thor and these
frost giants now the battle itself
largely takes
face off panel instead what we do is we
switch over to New York and we basically
have spider-man just kind of swinging
about and doing his own thing but then
he's basically met by the arrival of
Lady Freya now again all these ads
guardians that that previously existed
in the realm of Asgard have taken up
refuge on earth since it's like one of
the only safe places but one of the
things that I also want you guys to
notice here and Jason Erin hasn't really
said it to us so much as much as he's
shown it to us but one of the things
that Malekith is done is save Midgard
for last and the reason why is because
earth is home to some very very very
powerful people and so it'd be foolish
for Malekith to initiate the war of
realms and then seek earth as his first
place to conquer because Malekith has
been defeated on earth on more than one
occasion and so it makes sense of if
he's going to attack earth and you know
save it is the last realm and then in
turn like amass this gigantic army and
then send it there and so that's one of
the reasons why he kind of waited until
the very end but with spider-man showing
up here and then basically encountering
lady Freya it's actually sort of a funny
little encounter here she calls it like
the the man of spiders and is it urgent
because she's like my son has told me a
lot about you you know but you know I
didn't really believe the colorful
aspects but I guess it's all true but
the cool thing about this is that from
the perspective of Freya one of the
things to bear in mind is that while she
hasn't visited earth all that often
she's well aware of the exploits of Thor
on earth and so when she encounters
spider-man she knows just by the virtue
of what Thor has been telling her that
he's not someone to be trifled with and
even if he's not the weakest are not the
strongest person on earth he's certainly
somebody who will do whatever it takes
to win and he'll keep fighting because
he's an honorable warrior this is the
kind of thing that Thor communicates to
the Asgardians there and so that's why I
went like when when Hildegard and like
when Lady SIF show up when Jane Foster
shows up they're like Hildegard's just
like there's a giant spider thing here
let's kill it before it deposits already
its eggs in us you know and then and so
on and so forth since responses no
issues to superhero on earth because
again SIF has dealings with Earthlings
for Freya
her response here is I'm not really
worried about spider-man that's the
least of our concerns the realms are all
collapsing the realms are all falling
there they're literally being laid waste
to one by one by it by Malekith and in
fact they're all pretty much conquered
Asgard is really no more there's no safe
haven left the war of realms is coming
here because there's no place else for
it to go and it's kind of like this all
hands on deck situation the way that the
Jason arrant doesn't because you jump
from Doctor Strange you jump from
daredevil you jump to Wolverine you jump
to the Punisher he jabs always have been
herders who were all realizing
something's very wrong that something's
happening here and literally around the
time that happens the war of realms
manifests innocent hire T and it's a
full-blown invasion of New York from the
frost giants to the forces of cinder
who's the replacement for Surtur for
like all these different beings all
across the different realms this massive
army amassed by Malekith all just pours
into the city of New York and this is
kind of a funny thing here because the
way that Jason Erin plays this is almost
kinda like hey which these guys kind of
have a chance but at the same time
you're kind of like but no they don't
either there's not enough incredible
hulks
there's there's no Thor here he's on
Jotunheim why there's not there's like
we don't even know what the century is
doing he's out in space somewhere
because he's a perfectly blended version
of himself and the void like we don't
know where he is he's out there
somewhere
hi peering in the squadron supreme we
don't know where they are things are
popping off and like all the powerhouses
are seemingly nowhere to be seen here
and so of course this calls in the
Avengers it brings in like Carol Danvers
it brings an Iron Man it brings in Black
Panther you know Captain America and all
these different guys but for the most
part like they're a stopgap measure
there's no real way they can win here
it's almost a repeat of the events of
Ragnarok right like those guys remember
during the events of Ragnarok for Thor
disassembled it was literally Loki
leading a giant army against Asgard and
everybody died there was really nobody
who could stand against him and that's
what's happening here
you've got Malekith the accursed one of
the most powerful beings out there
you've got a you've got enchantress who
has insane levels of magical ability
you've got all these different
characters and for the most part like
you've got Captain America who can run
and run really fast and punch really
hard he's got a shield
you've got she-hulk who's almost The
Incredible Hulk but not really you got
Black Panther who can like move really
fast and he's the king of the Dead
presumably still you've got Carol
Danvers who's probably the strongest
among all the individuals here but he
got spider-man with a spider sense you
really have no one who can stand against
these guys you know there's no one here
right now who could really do anything
with these forces and that's what
happens they all start getting torn to
pieces and then suddenly you're met with
the arrival of Loki and that's when the
tide appears to change that's what it
really seems to shift but it's kind of a
crazy thing here because when Loki
starts addressing Neil starts talking to
his mom when he cuts off the hand of his
father he starts addressing his mom the
idea is well I don't trust you love he
and Loki's response as well I have a way
for you to learn to trust me I have a
way through the show that I'm a
genuinely good guy and one is up
happening is Loki basically sacrifices
himself by getting eaten by his father
which is kind of crazy because then it's
like well then where do you go
I'm here with Loki like what like what
else is there to do but that's the crazy
scenario is Loki basically said you have
to go find Thor you have to go locate
him if you guys don't have Thor there's
no way you can win all of it rests on
his shoulders and that's what's so
awesome here because now what it turns
into you is kind of a race to rescue
thort but while all that's going on when
the hounds of hell are coming out when
like the warriors of heaven are coming
out when you've got like the queen of
cinders again like the leader of muscle
I'm like the new Surtur like like when
you've got all these different
characters all showing up here the earth
seems to be doomed and meanwhile on
Jotunheim all you have is thor fighting
against what seems to be like this this
basically endless horde of frost giants
that just keeps coming and coming and
coming and coming and keeping him
sidetracked but even if he defeats them
all it won't matter because the Bifrost
is gone there's seemingly no way for
Thor to leave yo tin hunt there's no way
to get him out of there Thor's out there
by himself and it seems that for all
intents and purposes earth is literally
gonna be conquered but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like one heck of a
way to start the war of realms and I
will catch you all later peace